hello and welcome to the CBS this
morning Facebook live event I'm CBS News
contributor Jamie wax and with me is
Eric Davis of Fandango thanks for
joining us here in the Toyota greenroom
so we are gonna talk oscar's today which
is one of my favorite things to talk
with you about yes you and I follow
movies all year long are you in a very
very focused and specific way for all
the things you write on your blog and
the different things that you publish
for Fandango so what do you think of
2017 as a movie year Eric yeah I thought
it was a good year I I think what how we
wound up with a film a creature feature
nominated for 13 Oscars you know that
just speaks volumes I think about the
kind of year that it was I think it's a
year that we saw a lot of different
movies I think it's a year that we saw
genre movies kind of say look we're here
and we can be recognized as kind of Best
Picture nominees you know with get out
is in there as well as well as the shape
border and so I you know I think it's a
year where things are beginning to
change I feel very much like we are in
this age of empowerment and it's kind of
affecting the industry in some really
interesting ways it's affecting the
Academy it started affecting them I
think a couple of years ago when they
started bringing new members to their
Academy more diverse base a younger base
and so we're starting to see like that
maybe moonlight winning last year was a
sign of that as a sign of the changing
you know a lot of experts kind of rely
on historical stats to predict the
Oscars because that's how this much the
same it's been for so long is that you
can look back at its history and say
well this this this and this happened so
this is gonna win you can't really do
that anymore you know you could still do
it to a certain extent but I think
moving forward it's gonna be a lot more
of a wildcard and so this year I think
it is a wild card there's a lot of
really great films nominated still
smaller independent films not as big of
blockbusters but a good range of films a
good variety of movies and they're all
really entertaining to watch even the
distribution model is more diverse and
and crazier than ever
you've got mud bound which was produced
for Netflix which is their first I mean
it's a it's a leader in many categories
you it's their first nominated feature
that's not a documentary yeah yeah I
I they had a movie a couple years ago
called beasts of no nation that I I
thought was just fantastic and I walked
I've saw it on the big screen at the
Toronto Film Festival and I was like
this movie interests Elva gonna get a
nomination this movie is incredible I
had never seen a Juris kind of act that
way before and he was snubbed and that
was the year of Oscars so white and I
think you know Netflix has been trying
to kind of permeate this space and say
look we can make these kinds of movies
too and that I think there's just been
this kind of push and pull between
Academy members who are like well it's
not on you know 3,000 screens and so I
don't know if I can treat it like it's
like it's a Best Picture contender you
know but I think mud bound came along
and Netflix kind of reefs tragedies the
way that they push out some of these
movies and I think mud bound is has been
elevated above where beasts of no nation
was will that mean it will win an Oscar
I don't know as we were speaking before
I've been flip-flopping in terms of
whether or not it can hit in this one
category for adapted screenplay but I
think that Netflix is trying to make a
move and they're doubling down on
content they're making tons and tons of
movies some of them aren't well liked
and some of them are well liked and so I
think it's only a matter of time before
we see a Netflix in an Amazon in that in
that Best Picture kind of category I
mean according to a Netflix executive
they're spending eight billion dollars
this year yeah some seven veteran
projects that should get us a Best
Picture nominee eventually get you there
okay let's talk let's start with
supporting actor and actress okay this
is always a rich category for for
creativity and actually historically
some of the best on-screen performances
ever let's start with Supporting Actress
you've got mary j blige from my band who
is the first person ever nominated in an
acting category and for best song in the
same year right yeah and also if she
wins will be the first person winning in
an acting category who was directed by a
woman of color which is kind of crazy to
think that that's a actually a milestone
that could be reached this year it is
pretty crazy but that just speaks to
sort of what's happening right now at
the industry where these voices are
being elevated and we're starting to see
them permeate into these categories and
I think we're just going to see more
more of this and it's crazy to say that
these records are being broken because
he was like this should have been
happened like years ago but it's
starting to happen now it's gonna keep
happening well look at this category
this is a great group of performances
you got mary j blige for mudbone allison
janney for i Tanja Lesley Manville for
phantom thread Laurie Metcalf great
performance and Lady Bird and Octavia
Spencer in the shape of water which is
particularly great Supporting Actress is
always my favorite category because
they're always these kind of wild
performances that that steal scenes and
that you watch them and you're like yeah
this movie is really great but I loved
watching that character I will say when
I saw I Tanya also at the Toronto Film
Festival
I watched Allison Janney and I just
could not take my eyes off her I was
like this I was like I don't know what
other performances are gonna be in a
Supporting Actress category but this
this is her you know I've always loved
Allison Janney I think this is sort of
in some ways the year of the character
actor I think the frontrunners in these
acting categories are all sort of actors
that sometimes they've been the second
or third or fourth player in a movie but
you know they're always really great
they're always like the best part of
that movie absolutely I'll get to that
and supporting actors yes because
there's one there that you know but
Allison Janney yeah that's who I think
is gonna win it she's won all the
precursors I think it's I think that's a
good call I love Laurie Metcalf and Lady
Bird I think she could take it but
Allison Janney I think probably will and
I think the bird deserves a special bird
on her shoulder deserves a special award
supporting actor you've got Willem Dafoe
the Florida Project Woody Harrelson
three billboards outside Epping Missouri
Richard Jenkins for the shape of water
Christopher Plummer for all the money in
the world and Sam Rockwell who I was
referring to earlier three billboards
outside Epping Missouri Sam Rockwell
probably the most under s'en who is
almost always the best thing in every
movie yes and I think he'll take that
one what do you think yeah I think it's
gonna be Sam Rockwell I think there was
a momentum for Willem Dafoe and they're
still kind of is but nobody really saw
the Florida project which is a shame and
if you haven't seen the Florida project
I would say go see this movie because
they kind of dropped this veteran actor
amidst all of these people who've never
acted before you know in Brooklyn prints
who plays the little girl and her mom is
great and it's just just a really kind
of experimental film that and the way
they shot it and made it
is really great and willem dafoe is so
natural and great especially a guy who
usually plays a villain to see him in
this role was really refreshing but yeah
I think Sam Rockwell's is gonna take it
the versatility of that character you
know and I think there's been some
bubbling controversy a rare little
political backlash yes against the arc
of his character in this story but I
mean my sense is that look you don't
always have to like a character you
don't always have to like what they're
about but you could like watching them
you know and I like watching Sam
Rockwell's yeah I don't agree with where
he comes from and I don't necessarily
think he's redeemed at the end of this
movie at all but I just love watching
him all right let's go to to lead actor
now you've got Timothy sha'lame for call
me by your name Daniel day-lewis for
phantom thread Daniel kahlúa forget out
Gary Oldman for darkest hour and Denzel
Washington Roman J Israel Esquire you
and I were in agreement about who's
gonna win this category I believe when
we spoke on the CBS this morning
odd cast which you should also check out
are you still feeling that way yeah I
mean look without Gary Oldman in this
category I think Timothy sha'lame wins
it and makes a big big bold statement
and everybody kind of wraps their arms
around him and then he shoots up to sort
of superstardom which I think he stoked
and get there because I think he's got a
lot of fans but I think it's Gary Oldman
you watch Gary Oldman in darkest hour as
Winston Churchill and you say they
should have just given him the Oscars
six months ago for playing that role I
mean it's just you watch it and you're
like yep it's him it's him give him the
Oscar he's fantastic and it the makeup
job I think they're going to make up as
well because fantastic and it's
interesting to note that if he does win
Gary Oldman will be the first time in
history that two different actors have
won an Emmy and an Oscar six months
apart from playing the same character of
God yeah I'm playing Winston Churchill
in the crash it should just give
Churchill a posthumous Oscar and every
actor he plays in can passive yes peak
we're in peak church this is good
churches this is a good moment for time
all right lead actress we've got Sally
Hawkins the shape of water very
difficult and nuanced performance
Frances McDormand three billboards
outside having Missouri
Margot Robbie I Tania star Cerrone
Saoirse Ronan I should say Lady Bird and
Meryl Streep for the post her 21st Oscar
nomination record breaking for an actor
unbelievable make that John Williams we
should say his
51st oscar-nomination this year but but
she just still holds the record for the
acting categories who do you think's got
this category not Meryl Streep
unfortunately I mean if it was up to me
and I think we've spoken about this
before I love sally hawkins I love how
nuanced that performance is as she plays
a mute character in the shape of water
so everything about her she has to say
with her face and it's really incredibly
hard to do as an actress and so a lot of
respect to her for that role but I think
Frances McDormand it's gotta be in three
billboards she is just fantastic I was
watching a little bit of that again last
night and just watching her and she's so
forceful and nearly takes control of her
own sort of destiny in that movie in a
way that's just really fun to watch and
really crazy to watch and within a
character with clear boundaries she
makes some incredibly surprising choices
in the scenes just beautiful yes all
right
let's quickly go through Best Picture
we've got call me by your name darkest
hour Dunkirk get out
Lady Bird Phantom thread the post the
shape of water and three billboards
outside Epping Missouri who takes back
the Best Picture it's between the shape
of water three billboards and get out I
am going with get out you are jordan
peels movies gonna sneak in there and
surprise everyone i people have said
this movie is not a Best Picture
contender it's not best picture quality
I say you're out of your mind this is a
box-office juggernut it's widely
entertaining its wickedly
conversation-starter
and it's just the kind of movie that you
want to rally around it's a genre
game-changer what isn't Best Picture
material there so I think it's gonna be
get out but don't count out the shape of
water I think one of those movies is
gonna win I think that younger Academy
base it's gonna be on all of their lists
this get out and so if it's high on
their list I think it could I think
shape of water and three billboards
could split the vote and I think get out
slips in there I sure hope you're right
I'm rooting for it so I'm gonna agree
just out of sheer desire to see that
film get recognized for all the ways as
we spoke about it could have gone wrong
I don't think I've seen a movie that
could have gone off the rails and been
just not even bad just mediocre in some
way that was trying to balance three
genres that did it as artfully as that
one did all right
I should mention Erik Davis is going to
take over our Twitter account on CB
this morning during the Oscars in
live-tweet the Oscars if you've never
seen this man live tweet it's very
sarcastic knowledgeable if you love tiny
factoids that you never knew about every
performer presenter and category this is
the man to follow on Twitter so you can
check that out on CBS this morning's
twitter also check us out having a
conversation with Matt Zoller Seitz of
New York Magazine Roger Ebert calm on
the CBS this morning podcast I'm Jaime
wax thanks for watching CBS this morning
on Facebook live